when i'm juggling
i feel like i have a superpower
[Music]
to me it's just an amazing feeling to
keep lots of things in the air and to
keep these big patterns going
[Music]
sam malcolm is a combat juggler
the object of the sport is to keep all
three pins in the air while preventing
your opponent from doing likewise
light bumping and armed arm altercations
are permitted
the last juggler standing wins
[Music]
i got into combat juggling at about 3
a.m at a juggling convention
playing around with some friends
just trying to see who could be the last
one standing
we've all been to circuses we've all
seen variety acts but this is something
that makes it more of a sport
[Music]
if you're playing football you have to
put in the work to get good at football
juggling is no different you have to put
in hours and hours and hours of practice
you're not only accounting for the three
objects that you're juggling you have to
anticipate that there could be something
flying at your head
from 50 feet in the air because it's so
wild and crazy there's so many other
people playing
i warm up for combat juggling i jump
rope for about 10 minutes i work on
balancing things on my head and on my
face
there's a lot of wild throws there's a
lot of wild saves there's a lot of
jumping around and falling and running
on the ground and i try to go through
all of those things to get ready
you see
incredible plays by people like steph
curry or lebron james i can look at
those people and tell you like they'd be
great jugglers because they have that
awareness over their body
it's something new and exciting and
fresh something fun it's something
different
so i'm optimistic that it'll grow and
become something really great
usually people are really confused when
i tell them what i do i tell them like
yeah i own a fingerboard company
like those tech decks used to get in
sort of like yeah but professional
[Music]
skateboarding makes me feel awesome
it doesn't get boring
it's always a challenge there's no rules
fingerboarding and skateboarding both
have that
[Music]
[Applause]
i started fingerboarding in fourth grade
i had a lot of fun playing with the tech
decks and then i wanted to kind of
improve them
a lot of times the screws would come out
so i'd glue them in and just start
modifying things like that
and i just realized i could make them
better and better
a lot of kids wanted to buy them so i
kind of put a name on it and it grew
into this huge business over time
there's hundreds of thousands of people
out there that are into this
we are at the flat face rendezvous
location in dracut massachusetts and
it's pretty much a big building filled
with fingerboard parks and i do
huge events here where kids fly in from
all over the place to come and finger
board together
when you go into a contest it's crazy
because there's stadium seating and
there's everyone looking at you and
lighting and cameras my first few
contests i got crazy adrenaline rush
like you don't even remember the thing
after you do your run
[Music]
i don't do any warm-ups or exercises
with my hands for fingerboarding
apparently some people do cal aesthetics
the rules are pretty much you want to
use two fingers you'll have maybe 30
seconds or a minute or so and you just
do a run and there will be a whole bunch
of judges
they'll judge you on consistency style
the tricks you do
it's like really high pressure
[Music]
you can't even really put it into words
it's a crazy kind of feeling and
atmosphere
when so many people get together from
all over the world all over the country
and some of them it's like a really
really big deal to them
like that's the only thing they wanted
to do all year
it just
makes me super happy because i can
barely believe that i'm the reason
they're there
like because of something that i set up
and that i'm doing
[Music]
in many parts of the world scrabble is
viewed as a pastime as a game where
maybe old people play after retirement
and all that but scrabble in nigeria is
actually very big
it is seen as a sport there is an actual
nigerian scrabble federation under the
ministry of sports you have a lot of
young people hoping to end an actual
living from plain scrabble my name is
wellington jiggery and i'm the world
scrabble champion
[Music]
i started playing scrabble in 1996 when
my immediate elder brother taught me the
game it wasn't until six years after
that i was playing with some of my
neighborhood friends and they were like
ah you are quite good why not
playing tournaments and i was like wow
you made a play this in tournaments and
the rest is history has they say
having an african windy world scrabble
championship is bigger than i can
actually comprehend you needed to have
been in the hall to see the jubilation
of our other african brothers it was
something that everyone in africa that
plays scrabble has actually looked
forward to
nigeria is a very very diverse nation we
have well over 500 developed languages
but the major means of communication all
over nigeria is english and since
scrabble is based upon the english
vocabulary it's going to be a way of
helping each and every one improve their
command of the english language so what
do you think we should play from here
if i hadn't played scrabble i might have
been involved in some other not so
legitimate activities and i think
playing scrabble it keeps you on the
right track okay good we are not
blind to the fact that the level of
unemployment in the country is very very
immense so i came up with the wellington
foundation for scrabble and mind
development in africa there's a lot
of
similarities between
how
life actually goes and how scrabble goes
you get to understand that it's not all
the time that you get things your way
you really have to
make the best out of the little that you
are given
you know each country is known for a
particular spot brazil for example is
known for football we are hoping to make
scrabble a nigerian sport by if you
mention scrabble in any part of the
world nigeria should come to mind
[Music]
[Music]
take a pagan festival chariots pulled by
bikes and a tiny welsh town and you get
whatever this is
this story takes place in the welsh
countryside in the town of landword
land worded flannerted wells we are the
smallest town in the uk
and this is lindsey ketteringham he runs
the local hotel in town it's called the
niath arms hotel town today is a small
farming community primarily everybody
knows everybody else
day-to-day life is
generally pretty quiet around here
except on event day
[Music]
the mountain bike chariot racing
championship is an event that was
conceived to be part of a roman festival
that we hold each january the rules of
the race are to get round in the fastest
time possible the course starts off on a
short tarmac stretch then becomes a
rough stony road with puddles and bumps
and eventually comes back to the finish
along a tarmac stretch which has speed
bumps it's not a simple task we do
encourage people to
dress up as the romans did as you can
see people enter into the spirit of it
which is what it's all about okay but
ben hur style bike racing isn't
everything that this tiny town does
we do the events such as man versus
horse bug snorkeling
and it all started back in the 70s
sanoted wells was the center of the pony
trekking industry in britain and in the
1970s unfortunately the industry went
into serious decline at that point the
local business people started looking
for ideas to boost the economy and came
up with the idea of running events
things that were slightly different and
unusual
it's great
to see
the success of the events see people
enjoying themselves
and
it's great to be able to share
what this part of the
countryside has to offer the aim is to
maintain
the great community
that we have here even to help it grow
but not too much we don't want to lose
our smallest town status hey i hear you
lindsay
how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything we have
the opportunity to do something that no
one else does this isn't played anywhere
else in the world so yeah like it's
serious like we want to win
[Music]
we're here to watch unicycle football
it's football on unicycles
[Music]
we stick the nfl rules as closely as
possible
says there are a few exceptions because
we're riding a unicycle
we play five on five two receivers a
blocker a center and a quarterback
everything has to be done on a wheel
the second your foot touches the ground
you're done
each team plays 14 games there's 56
regular season games total then wild
card playoffs then playoffs and then the
super bowl every sunday some people have
been doing this for 10 years now
my team the black house we're undefeated
and we're going to be playing the
reigning champs the herons
bulldoze them over bulldozer this game
is very important because we want to
maintain our undefeated status leading
up to the super bowl
they're definitely gunning for us
they're practicing just for us
i think that a lot of times people come
to this game what shocks them
is the level of play
we're crashing at 15 miles an hour it's
not a joke
some people get seriously injured
most people learn to ride unicycle
because they came and witnessed this
event and they're like i've got to do
this
once you catch that first ball
once you get that first rush once you
hear the crowd scream your name once
that's a feeling you can't get anywhere
else that's almost like a religion
church to us here
there's passion you know it's a show
it's a spectacle
it's also a sport
i've cherished every minute of it
you can't replace it with anything
there's nothing else like it
at all
[Music]
you